well greetings it is good to be back
with you all and an especially warm
welcome if this is your first time with
us Adventist or otherwise so tonight we
are going to be listening to an
individual that a lot of you have asked
about for a minute now um just happens
to be that now is when we're getting
around to it we're going to be listening
to uh Neo Adventist Dr Tim Jennings from
come and reason Ministries I want to by
saying that Tim Jennings is a smart guy
um I read his book uh it's been quite
some time now the god-shaped brain some
years ago um and he said some pretty
informative stuff uh but it's definitely
built upon the foundational Adventist
claim that the primary issue with
mankind is a faulty understanding of the
character of God and you know if the
brain can be engaged at that level
people will come to God if they can
shift the way that the person thinks
about God that sort of thing the uh the
standard sort of great controversy Mo if
you will but it's also important to note
that Dr Jennings clearly dislikes the
Western Christian tradition I've noticed
this with him uh anytime that I listen
to him namely though the belief that the
true God is indeed a god of wrath and
that wrath was appeased in the offering
up of the son by God the Father it is
also clear like we will see tonight that
he feels that vestages of that are
present within Adventist theology
obviously it was concocted in in the
west but specifically regarding the
atonement which is why he has developed
a name for himself within the Seventh
Day Adventist world he also has his own
Bible paraphrase called the remedy um
which is something we will look at later
if you thought the uh the Blurred word
was bad aka the clear word um yeah the
remedy paraphrase makes the the clear
word look like an ancient biblical
manuscript but most notably is his
unique take on the Adventist doctrine of
the investigative judgment which is what
we're going to be be uh listening to
tonight in part one as we work our way
through his presentation in a multi-part
fashion but for those that are new to
this I used the phrase Neo
Adventist what is
that we have an article on the answering
adventism website titled what is Neo
adventism in part it says
quote Neo adventism is a term you may
hear us use in article or video we
coined it to distinguish traditional
Orthodox 7th Day Adventist Doctrine from
its modernized
reinterpretations this newer flavor of
adventism reflects a blending of
Evangelical thought with the
foundational 7th a Adventist framework
particularly the great controversy
theme while Neo Adventists often profess
alignment with the denomination's stated
beliefs they frequently articulate
position that diverge significantly from
Orthodox SDA
teachings this inconsistency can create
confusion among those seeking clarity
about Adventist Doctrine and practice
often making Neo adventism far more
theologically
dangerous close
quote and that is exactly correct the
Neo Adventist flavors of adventism have
done a good job of blurring the
lines and making adventism seem
theologically in
uous but what you will find is that
under the surface it is the same
poisonous product just packaged in a new
rapper which is why tonight's
presentation is happening we will begin
like I said a multi-part exam of Dr
jenning's presentation on his theory and
I want to focus particularly on how
despite his departure from SDA
Orthodoxy he still has a great
controversy worldview like every other
Adventist which is why I call him a Neo
adven
at the end of the day that's what binds
all of
adventism and no matter how much the Neo
Adventist try and do the the lipstick on
the theological Pig thing it will not
Salvage what is fundamentally broken
adventism is not salvageable folks to to
salvage it would be to rid it of its
entire identity and its pillars
resulting in there really being no no
use for it but something else I need to
remind you all of before we listen
you need to remember that within
Adventist theology the word atonement
uniquely refers to the investigative
judgment so adventism does not mean the
same thing Christians do when discussing
the atonement because none of us believe
this unique Doctrine only they do and I
want to say something here before we get
into
this I've noticed amongst Advent a
scholarship they're all trying to appeal
now to to David Moffett from St Andrews
over in Scotland he's in individual I I
was in his paper actually before
starting this his Hebrews in the
atonement paper I I've also heard Roman
Catholics appealing to Dr Moffet
ironically
enough and it's interesting because they
think that by appealing to someone like
this it shows that see other people are
coming on board other people are coming
on
board now what Dr moffett's putting
forth and even Roman Catholics even
Roman Catholics that think the atonement
is ongoing that does not now vindicate
the investigative judgment so just
remember that when you hear Advent a
scholarship or individuals we get people
that comment this stuff I had a guy copy
and paste an excerpt from Dr moffett's
article uh I don't know a couple weeks
ago folks they don't have a great
controversy worldview that does not
vindicate adventism so just remember
that but like I said atonement in the
Adventist model refers specifically to
the investigative judgment as SDA
scholar worship even recognizes you can
see an example of this in the book
salvation Contours of AOS soteriology
which is on the bookshelf behind me
where SDA Theologian John Pauline writes
quote one of the most debated topics of
Christian theology is expressed in these
questions why the cross what really
happened at the cross the answers to
these questions have been widely debated
under the general heading of the
atonement but when seventh day
Adventists approached the matter of
atonement in immediate dilemma is
perceived when Adventists talk about
atonement they refer specifically to
what Jesus is doing now in the Heavenly
Sanctuary on the other hand when
Scholars outside the Seventh Day
Adventist Church discuss the atonement
they refer specifically to the cross of
Jesus Christ and what God was doing
there close
quote which is is why Dr Jennings has
attracted both critics and supporters
within the movement many Neo Adventists
admire him for offering what they see as
a solution to a longstanding doctrinal
issue that has plagued the SDA movement
since its
Inception others criticize him for
introducing what they view as a
deception by reinterpreting this
Doctrine away from Ellen White and the
SDA
Pioneers so the focus of tonight isn't
on Tim Jennings as a person it's not
about Tim Jennings the man
but on how at the end of the day it's
all the same it's all the same the the
Neo Adventist the liberal Adventist the
conservative Adventist the whole
Spectrum at its core is no different
it's the same toxic product from the
organization AKA The Great controversy
worldview that they're trying to get you
to adopt but it's packaged for different
audiences in a different way that's why
people like Dr Jennings are allowed to
exist in the organization without the
organization completely booting people
like this because at the end of the day
they're just accepting the fact that
there's various people out there like Ty
Gibson and David asri at light Bears
they do the same sort of thing adventism
is just like everyone else basically
yeah we have a couple nuances here and
there that type
thing I'm not saying Dr Jennings is
nefarious when I say that I'm sure he's
a genuine sincere guy who's passionate
about helping people most doctors are
he's a psychiatrist but we gotta call a
spade a spade
his alternate teachings are the excuse
that a lot of Adventists are using to
remain within this deceptive
organization but one last thing before
we get into
it if you like what we are doing here
please consider becoming a channel
member you will gain access to not only
our membersonly video library including
members only live streams but our behind
the curtain Discord server which just
launched a couple weeks ago where you
can connect with the answering adventism
Community including myself you can ask
questions get behind the scenes looks at
what's upcoming and much more so if you
want to join simply visit the link in
the description box down below click the
little join button down below this video
or visit our Channel homepage like you
see on screen where you will find the
same button in two places This truly is
a group effort so thank you all so much
for your support with that said let's
get into
it we're going to talk about the
investigative judgment through the
healing lens how many have heard of the
doctrine called the investigative
judgment okay how many have a clear
understanding of what that
is yeah have you found that Doctrine to
be kind of sometimes I mean maybe you
studied it but it's like as you read it
it's like I must be missing something I
must be some piece I'm I'm not quite
getting because it seems pretty
difficult to comprehend at times Well I
hopefully that we'll present this to you
in a way that maybe you've never
considered it before and I tended to an
evidence-based approach I'm going to try
to put the pieces of of evidence
together to see if we can't bring it
bring it to to home for
you yes Dr Jennings this is a very
complex Doctrine and I'd venture to say
that 95% of 7th Day Adventists couldn't
confident uh confidently explain it to
you and an even larger percentage
couldn't explain its role within the
larger seven-step Sanctuary model that
it is a part of and here's why this is a
major problem
folks ah yes
yes as
always the Adventist Pope had this to
say and yes I say Pope because this
organization tells us that Ellen White's
writings correct inaccurate
interpretations of scripture and that
their supposedly divinely inspired
Revelation from God
himself hence why I have photoshopped a
miter onto her head from G great
controversy page 488 she writes
quote those who would share the benefits
of the savior's
mediation should permit nothing to
interfere with their duty to perfect
Holiness in the fear of
God the precious hours instead of being
given to pleasure to display or to gain
seeking should be devoted to an Earnest
prayerful study of the word of
Truth the subject of the sanctuary in
the investigative judgment should be
clearly understood by the people of
God clearly understood
all need a knowledge for themselves of
the position and work of their great
high
priest
otherwise
uhoh it will be impossible for them to
exercise the faith which is essential at
this
time or to occupy the position which God
designs them to fill every individual
has a soul to save or to lose each has a
case pending at the bar of God oh that's
legal language the bar
each must meet the great judge again
legal language face to face close
quote yet what Dr Jennings is going to
present is a reimagining of this
teaching more than likely as a result of
the Orthodox teaching being a total mess
and complex web to navigate and
learn but Ellen White carries more
weight than the good
doctor that's always the rub when it
comes to those that have tried to
Rebrand or reimagine Orthodox SDA
teaching which is why I said earlier
that it ends up creating more problems
than it
solves very clearly she warned that
those who do not understand this
Doctrine risk their ET eternity because
they need to understand they have a case
pending at the bar of God and if you
want to share in the benefits of Christ
mediation which is necessary for
salvation
you can't let anything interfere with
your duty to perfect
Holiness
otherwise
otherwise it will be impossible for a
person to exercise the faith necessary
to occupy the position that God has
designed them to
fill and not just the investigative
judgment folks also the sanctuary
Doctrine as a whole Which is far more
complex than just the prear uh the
pre-advent
judgment and let's not forget what she
meant by Perfect Holiness I show this
all the
time we inevitably always get Adventists
that think no no no it's just she just
meant trying your best she's just using
the words of
Paul same book page
623 while the investigative judgment is
going on it's what they mean by the word
atonement one needs to seek to become
perfect perfect in Christ thankfully she
then goes on to Define that for us where
she gives us an
analogy she uses Jesus being tempted by
Satan in the
wilderness and says not a single sin
could be found within him that could
give the devil a
foothold and this is the condition that
one must be found in when probation
closes well probation closes when the
investigative judgment
ends and that's when the time of trouble
will
start you'll be without a
mediator and Satan will be
loosed and he'll be able to find a
foothold if you haven't gotten to this
sinlessly perfect State and you won't
make it notice the last sentence what
condition must one be found
in as sinless as
Jesus so remember this tonight as we
listen to Dr Jennings evidence-based
healing model okay and I'll repeat don't
give me wrong Jennings is a smart guy no
doubt about
it don't think there aren't smart
individuals that are caught up in this
movement folks there are and I say that
a lot Dr Jennings is a brilliant man but
he's not a
theologian and to try and propose an
alternate model that deviates from the
quotes we just read strikes a straight
blow to the entire SDA edifice death
blow because it logically leads to the
entire structure not being able to stand
upon scrutiny the the truth should be
the Anvil that can wear out any
Hammer so whether he recognizes that I I
don't know because if you're out of sync
with her then you call her into question
and she's one of the pillars and as Dr
Douglas has told us numerous times
they're mutually supportive clusters
they support one another if one Falls
the whole thing falls apart they need it
all you can't just come along just hand
wave her away oh she's just a great
commentator yeah maybe for you maybe for
you
but what I do know is that the SDA
Church tells us the quotes I read are
divinely inspired claims direct
Revelation from the throne room of God
and what I also know is the SDA church
is handing out millions of copies of the
great
controversy billions including digital
copies evidencing that they stand by the
words and teachings contained within
it and what she said is ultimately
necessary within the the larger great
controversy Paradigm that Tim himself
possesses as an
Adventist all these new and kind of you
know zany theories to try and make
something toxic not be toxic only result
only results in a worse
toxin because at its root this
doctrine's false it's Antichrist
anti-gospel
Etc no amount of reimagining will change
that especially when the good doctor
just told us that his proposed model is
evidence-based
so first the investigative judgment is a
unique Doctrine to the 7th Adventist
Church as far as I know no other
Christian organization has this
particular Doctrine this Doctrine came
out of the millerite movement millerite
movement in uh 1840 in 18 early 1800s uh
predicted that Christ was going to come
in 1844 then he didn't come in the
aftermath of the great disappointment of
1844 people wanted to understand what
happened how do we understand this Bible
prophecy we were so sure something was
going to happen and in the aftermath of
that disappointment they eventually
developed the doctrine called the
investigative judgment Daniel 8:14 is
the prophecy that William Miller used to
predict the date of
1844 and so the the high points of what
the traditional model of the
investigative judgment taught within
adventism has been is that the 2300 day
prophecy ended in
1844 Christ entered the most holy place
of the sanctuary in heaven in
1844 he began cleansing the sanctuary of
the sins of the
people this uh also required the
investigation of uh of records and and
judgment and investigative judgment to
determine who was fit and who was unfit
whose sins have been accounted for and
whose sins had not been accounted for
all cases uh of the professed followers
of Christ get reviewed and findings are
made God's judgment in who he allows
into heaven and who he doesn't is
Vindicated he's proven that that he is
right in his discernment and and
judgment
and it uh the investigative judgment
ends with human uh ends human probation
and it culminates in the second coming
of Christ this these points are the
points you'll find if you look in the 27
fundamental beliefs the 28 fundamental
beliefs on the investigated judgment
these are the high points of what this
Doctrine kind of brings
together the entire presentation and
historical view of this is predicated as
a legal or taught as a legal prop
process it's the investigation of
Records legal accounting of sins
judicial findings rendering of legal
judgments removing of record of sins
from books in heaven this entire thing
is predicated on this
view single idea that God's law
functions like human
law a system of rules that you impose
that require external
adjudication a Judicial finding of some
magistrate to investigate and come to
conclusion most thinking people
recognize there's some flaw in that he
he who knows all things then from the
beginning he doesn't need to investigate
he knows everything there's no need for
that there there's many many questions
that arise in this Doctrine for people
when it's presented in this in this view
that God functions like human courts
function all right so one thing I want
to point out first notice that the way
Tim described this teaching historically
his bullet points is how I have numerous
times yet Adventists will claim I'm
misrepresenting and
lying oh
brother yeah Tim Tim knows Tim knows now
what I I don't know if he knows is if he
understood what he tacitly admitted here
but wow wow
Tim I couldn't agree
more but Dr Jennings why is the
inclination to try and revamp this
ridiculous sounding doctrine that in his
words most thinking people here and
think that sounds ridiculous
contradictory and
confusing why isn't the thinking huh
well that falsifies
adventism it's odd to me that a
psychiatrist would go down the road of
trying to revitalize something that they
recognize sounds foolish and
illogical especially considering that as
a card carrying
Adventist one would have to uphold all
28 fundamental beliefs and how they are
formulated especially this one
considering it's the whole Lynch pin of
1844 Dr Jennings contention in this area
is with his propus that his movement
tells us was divinely inspired in
correcting of inaccurate interpret
ations of scripture we just read from
her yeah she uses legal
language she's the one that claimed to
be shown all this stuff in Vision
regarding its legal
framework an entire aspect of the model
is titled the courtroom
scene like I showed earlier once
probation closes you'll be left to stand
without a
mediator Satan will be accusing you
Jesus will be advocating but only for
those who made it through the
investigative judgment those that didn't
Satan's accusation against them will
stand and it was Ellen White that
recognized that Daniel 8:14 was the
pillar of the millerite movement and
that that pillar carried over by
necessity into the 7th Day Adventist
movement because the reinterpretation of
that error was the alleged get out of
jail free card for being wrong about the
second coming happening in
1844 this quote is from the chapter of
great controversy titled what is the
sanctuary all of what he presented on
his slide was confirmed by Ellen White
who was supposed to function for their
movement as the Divine stamp of approval
on doctrinal understanding by way of
that supposedly helping to enhance the
Bible
storyline but it also doesn't contradict
it in any
way that would include the legal
framework of the doctrine integral to
the entire
system what would I
ECT is that the other problem he
recognizes is that if that is the case
then there's no way to bypass the
sinless perfectionism the
legalism all that stuff comes with
it perfectionism folks tends to be the
other area one of the other areas that
the Neo Adventists have tried to
distance themselves
from but since it's intimately connected
to the investigative
judgment no amount of reimagining
hand waving no it it won't remove that
this is Central this is another Central
aspect a prepared
people victory over sin all these
buzzword they use to try and make it
sound more Pious and Noble than it
is you can't handwave that stuff away
that's part of how the Adventist God is
going to vindicate himself which is what
Tim and the Neo Adventists are supposed
to be all
about part of God being Vindicated is
you demonstrating you can keep the law
correctly oh more legal
language but I want to suggest to you I
want to show you the evidence that in
fact this idea that God's law functions
like human law is the
lie that's infected the sanctuary or
contaminated that the sanctuary Doctrine
is to be cleansed or the sanctuary is to
be cleansed
from how do you see God's law do you see
God in his law is designer Builder space
time reality his laws the laws upon
which life are constructed including the
physical laws but also the moral laws
and just like physical laws laws of
gravity laws of thermodynamics you can't
change them you cannot change moral laws
and just like when you violate physical
laws there's damage to you when you
violate moral laws it Sears the
conscience hardens the heart warps the
character takes you further and further
out of harmony with the the kingdom of
love and God's design for for life or do
you see God's laws no no different than
a Roman Caesar making up a rule and then
threatening to punish and kill you if
you don't keep his rule
designer I just described and the
dictator the rules imposed with threats
of punishment well let's look at the
Bible what does the bible describe as
God's law in Old Testament if you
Faithfully obey the commands I am giving
you today to love the Lord your God and
to serve him with all your heart and
soul then all these various blessings
follow New Testaments even expounds this
more Romans love does no harm to its
neighbor therefore love is fulfillment
of the law Galatians the entire law is
summed up in a single command love your
neighbor as yourself James if you keep
the Royal law found in script script
love your neighbors yourself you're
doing right but maybe we should turn to
Jesus who said love Lord your God with
all your heart mind soul and strength
and neighbors yourself all law hangs on
this all of
it now this is not simple compassion
this is not simple empathy or concern
this is functional it's operational it's
constructional it's how God can built
reality to function and when God built
his reality it's an expression of his
nature of love and Paul says in Romans
that God's divine nature is seen and
what he has made so that men that excuse
there are many examples of this the one
that's most easy for people to grasp is
the the law of respiration Every Breath
You give you give away carbon dioxide to
the plants and they give oxygen back to
you which is a never-ending circle of
giving upon which life is built but
you're free to transgress the law you
can tie a plastic bag over your head and
selfishly hoard your carbon dioxide to
yourself but the wages of that is this
is a physical example of exactly what
happens when you violate God's moral law
you're cutting yourself off from the
source of life and you will die I'm
going to tell you a secret now when was
the last time you got up in the morning
and
said man I've got to breathe
today 12 breaths a minute let's see 60
minutes in an hour 24 hours that's a lot
of
[Music]
breathing you see when you're healthy
you don't even think about it breathing
is easy but when you're really really
sick breathing can become painful it can
become hard you might even need
artificial respiration to help you
breathe
when God has his way in our life and
fixes what's wrong inside us it will be
as easy to love other people as it is to
breathe that's the natural god-designed
function for all of his beings but we're
really sick we don't naturally love
we're fear-based and self-centered and
afraid of getting hurt we're
self-protective and so we need God's
artificial love respirator to help us
love well now but his goal is to fix us
and set us free to love like he loves
all right so this sounds like the
standard rhetoric often used by Neo
Adventists like Ty Gibson where the word
love is reduced to this you know Buzz
word that's repeated just ad nauseum
dozens of times in a single
presentation he however presented a
false dichotomy by asking whether you
view God as a designer or a
dictator the problem lies in how he
frames
dictator because much of what he class
ifies under that label like we're going
to see aligns with Biblical descriptions
of God's
justice which makes his framing
problematic God of course is not a
dictator
however it's also true that God's law
does to some
extent aim to regulate and control
Behavior but by oversimplifying things
as he
did he creates a flawed starting point
for the
presentation let's take for example what
Paul says regarding natural law in
Romans 2 and we're actually going to
read through some of it not just do the
bullet Point Breeze over because what he
mentioned in Romans 1 is chained to this
and it actually completely backfires on
what he's going to go on to say here
later regarding what Christians
allegedly
believe I talk about this pretty
regularly that the issue I have with the
Adventist view of the law is not the law
itself but the SDA Church's
misunderstanding an unlawful use of the
law well one of the valid uses put forth
in scripture is that it is to restrain
the evildoers and protect the righteous
from the
wicked notice Romans 22-16 for example
we
read for all who have sinned without the
law will also perish without the law and
all who have sinned under the law will
be judged by the
law for it's not the hearer of the law
hearers of the law who are righteous
before God but the doers of the law who
will be justified for when Gentiles who
do not have the law by
Nature by
Nature do what the law
requires they are a law to
themselves even though they do not have
have the
law they show that the work of the law
is written on their
hearts while their conscience also Bears
witness and their conflicting thoughts
accuse or even excuse them on that day
when according to my gospel God judges
the secrets of men by Christ
Jesus thus the reading of God's holy and
inspired
word this passage is part of Paul's
explanation that both Jews and Gentiles
are equal in their standing before God
as Sinners talked about this before the
book of Romans is broken up into three
parts chapters 1 through three deal with
the sin problem four through
roughly 10
11 deal with the remedy to that problem
the remaining chapters to 16 deal with
how should we live in light of that good
news
now so this is part of Paul's
explanation to Jewish converts who would
have been under the
impression I'm not a dog like a
gentile I'm a
Jew and Paul here is explaining to them
no all he's going to get on to saying in
chapter three all have sinned and fall
short of the glory of God but in this
particular paropy he's pointing out
something to them regarding how even
Gentile who didn't have the law given to
them they still have a
law and it's
natural so follow with that Paul's
Jewish Christian audience may have been
tempted to believe that they were
Superior to Gentiles because God gave
the law to the Jewish people and
established the Covenant with them at
SI but Paul then rebukes this
mindset pointing out that being Jewish
does not place above
Gentiles in the sight of
God he explains that even Gentiles who
were not given the law follow its moral
precepts when they obey their conscience
why because natural or moral law is
written on the conscience of every
person Jew and Gentile
alike and what Tim cited from in the
previous
chapter Paul had already established
that all of humanity is without excuse
before God and why is
this well Paul says it's because of
General Revelation the creation itself
and God's sustaining power have made his
existence known to all
people as a part of this created order
the human conscience then serves as an
innate conviction mechanism that's
placed by God within all of
humanity this this is also an example
here folks that I'm going to upset some
people by this so be
it this is also evidence that Paul's not
just talking about ceremonial law in in
Romans
folks it's not the ceremonial law that's
written upon the conscience natural law
moral law there's a distinction in the
law between moral ceremonial and civil
we're going to be looking at some of
that a little bit later we're going to
get into some Thomas
aquinus but
nevertheless Paul's point to the Jews
here is clear
so what if God gave you the law
externally that doesn't make you
Superior to Gentiles before
God because even Gentiles act morally
when they follow their conscience
because the natural law is inscribed on
every human
heart which again is bolstering his
fundamental overarching point which is
that we all stand condemned before God
equally which he verbatim states in the
next
chapter so what problem does this copy
present for Dr jenning's
claim well verses 14 and 15 clearly show
that the law operates internally on the
conscience as a restraining mechanism to
guide and influence
behavior it convicts individuals when
they act wrongly and it excuses them
when they do what is morally right and
praise God for that think about how many
people have in a fit of
rage considered going out and doing
heinous things but their conscience
stopped them that was the final barrier
mechanism they couldn't physically be
restrained so their conscience restrains
them because God has put that within
them unless they've just seared it to
where it just doesn't even function
anymore but Tim's framing is
fundamentally flawed viewing the law as
a behavioral control mechanism does not
contradict or negate the scriptural
reference to the law in relation to
love it just means that one must study
the subject more
comprehensively and be able to think in
proper
categories it isn't enough to just proof
text all the places where the Bible
mentions the law being a fulfillment of
love to the detriment of whatever else
is
said the real issue in this area for
orthodox Adventist Theology and the
investigative judgment lies in their
misuse of the law and their flawed
understanding of the Law's
purpose they erroneously teach Orthodox
adventism that the law law combined with
faith establishes a right relationship
with God and that a person's obedience
to the law then sustains and maintains
this relationship you're in by faith
kept by your obedience this is the new
perspective on Paul nonsense covenantal
nomism Jesus opened the way for you to
enter but then to remain you have to do
your part again this is historically
what's been called covenantal G nomism
in by faith kept by obedience no that's
not the role of
obedience and it's my hypothesis that
this fundamental flaw is what has
resulted in Dr Jennings trying to figure
out a
workaround Christianity the early
Christian Church the Apostolic Church
functioned on this Jesus gave of himself
sacrificed himself in love to heal and
to
save Greater Love is no man that he give
his life for a friend this is how we
know what love is that Christ gave his
life for us we give our lives for our
brothers for God so loved the world that
he gave his only begotten son whoever
seeks to save his life will lose it but
he who surrenders or gives his life for
me will find it there's this principle
upon which life is built that God is
trying to communicate to us the early
church operated this way you see them
Living Community sacrificing to help
those less fortunate giving of
themselves others refusing to go to war
against the Roman State instead dying
self-sacrificial as Martyrs in the
gospel spread in the first century
rapidly something changed in
Christianity though what changed in
Christianity how they understood God's
law and therefore how they understood
God Daniel actually prophesied this was
going to happen he prophesizes a little
horn power is going to rise and this
power is going to seek to change God's
law and so the question how did the idea
and notice I put the word idea because
can human beings actually change God's
law no we can't do it we can only change
the way we think or the idea concept of
God's law how did the idea of God's law
get changed imperialism that God's
government or laws function no different
than the way human beings laws function
now what is the evidence that I can show
you from history to prove my point on
this well what church committee ever got
together and decided to change the laws
of gravity and vote in committee to
change the law of respiration I
understand in California there's a lot
of fires going on right now there's some
bad air quality why doesn't the
committee get together and say if you
join the Aven church when the when the
pollution level gets to a certain level
we won't require that you
breathe you'll be free of that
burden you laugh at me but there's a
point here Church committees never vote
to make those changes do they and
there's a reason why is the reason
because they can't it won't make any
difference whatever so what would it
mean then if a church committee did vote
to change God's law wouldn't it be proof
and evidence that they don't see God's
law as design law they see it just as an
arbitrary set of rules it's changeable
and in fact you know the history The
Church did change the Commandments God's
law the worship from one day to another
remov the second commandment about
images split the 10th into two they made
changes to the law why would they do
that because they don't see God's law as
design law and so the real change to
God's law is not the change in the day
of worship the real change to God's law
is how you conceive of his law a system
of rules like men make
that God has to adjudicate and inflict
punishments for breaking that's the real
change that infected Christianity that
the little horn was going to come
across oh brother okay get comfortable
folks there's a lot we have to look at
here
okay first I'd point out that Jesus
himself equated sin as a debt and debt
is a legal
term sin absolutely has a legal aspect
Dr Jennings that's not where it ends but
it's absolutely included cross reference
The Lord's Prayer
folks Matthew records forgive us our
debts Luke records forgive us our
sins even says debt later in the same
passage Jesus equated sin with legal
debt further more Colossians 2 what was
nailed to the cross was the sin debt
I've gone into this before you can check
out this article from our website where
I go into it further read the text
carefully folks there's a lot of
arguments about Colossians 2 for all
sorts of various reasons between all
sorts of various groups Protestants
Catholics Adventists Protestants
Adventist
evangelicals torist people Hebrew Roots
people Everyone goes to Colossians
2 read the text carefully pay attention
to what's being AB ated canell done away
with there are a lot of arguments around
what this passage is
saying that it's talking about the law
being nailed to the cross only
ceremonial laws being nailed to the
cross
Etc but if you pay close
attention you'll find that what's nailed
to the cross is what Christ
bore Peter tells us in his epistle
first
epistle or sorry Second
Epistle that our sins were placed on
Christ on the
tree Paul's own theology confirms this
in 2 Corinthians 5 he who knew no sin
became
sin what's being canceled in Colossians
2 is the sin debt of
Believers and like I show in the article
not trying to get into all this tonight
but the word that's translated
handwriting of ordinances or certificate
of debt some translations will
say that word is is what in in just
literature I guess it's a broader term
than just
theological the term that's translated
for those phrases is a hopo
legam which is simply the very fancy way
to refer to a word that only occurs in a
single text in a single time in a body
of
text the only place that the word
appears in all of scripture is there in
Colossians 2 and it's a legal term it's
a legal
term so my hypothesis is that Dr
Jennings has been influenced to a degree
by Eastern
Theology and he has tried to infuse some
of that into Orthodox Adventist teaching
as a saline to try and repair what is
badly wounded now I don't want to
misrepresent the east
here but my understanding is that the
Orthodox Churches have a similar
rejection of the legal framework around
sin and they uphold uh they uphold um
and also advocate for a predominantly
healing focused framework like a
medicinal you Orthodox in the audience
can correct me if I'm wrong down in the
comments and to be fair I got to be fair
some of what Tim presents sounds like
some of the ideas found in the likes of
the capid ocian fathers like Gregory of
Nissa
he taught and believed that God's
punishments were essentially strictly
medicinal not retributive or
punitive that's basically what Tim is
trying to get at here it very clearly
sounds like he's been influenced by like
an Eastern way of
thinking like an Eastern esque spin on
the investigative judgment which makes
sense because he's a doctor and is
probably passionate about healing
but he clearly does not like the Latin
Western Christian tradition's usage of
legal language surrounding
atonement but it's because of the Bible
friends it's because of the Bible God is
the one that uses legal language to help
us understand and describe this and I'm
not saying the atonement is only legal
only
legal of course it has more Dimensions
than
that but my point is that it's very hard
to come away from reading the New
Testament and see all that it has to say
about atonement and not recognize all of
the legal language that is used to
describe such but I have to point
something out here of vital importance
okay I mentioned Ty Gibson earlier well
we've heard this exact same thing from
him numerous times when he was preaching
about the reformation and what was
taking place
there like Gibson Jennings presents the
early church as being identified by
their love for one
another and yes Jesus told the disciples
before he ascended and they were worried
that uh you know they were they were
fearful because um of his of his
departure he said the comforter would be
sent to them the Holy Spirit they'd be
guided by him
Etc on top of this that the culture
around them would see their love for
each other and that's how they would
know that they were Jesus's disciples in
his physical
absence but that's only one side of the
coin
the gospel is not just hallmarked by
Behavior the church is not just
hallmarked by
Behavior it's also hallmarked by
Doctrine
Doctrine he talked about what we see in
the early church regarding behavior but
Dr
Jennings what we don't see at all in the
early church is the investigative
judgment or a great controversy
worldview which brings all sorts of
details from outside of the Bible
from a pre-earth origin
story to then try and make sense of the
Bible in light of that
information yeah none no one in the
early church had that no one in the
early church contrary to their claims as
we've looked at numerous times believed
about the Sabbath like they do even if
you wanted to Grant to
them they were all seventh day
sabbatarians which I don't but they
didn't believe that it was the mark of
Sunday was going to be the mark of the
beast all this other stuff which they
appeal to present truth on but the point
being is they didn't believe all
that well the SDA Church claims that the
investigative judgment is a part of the
Gospel yet the apostles didn't teach
it it's entirely novel to adventism as
Tim even recognized in his introduction
where he said as
much I have shown Source after Source
after Source on this platform where the
SD Church itself recognizes that this
Doctrine is entirely novel to the 19th
century and yet they say it's part of
the
Gospel it's part of this Everlasting
gospel that's being
restored so Dr Jennings my question for
you what committee in history voted to
change the
gospel since what your movement
proclaims to be the gospel is an
entirely novel present truth message
that only you all
have Paul says there's only one gospel
Galatians 1 6-9 and anyone preaching a
different one is twice cursed the
Apostle tells us twice cursed by
God but then we heard him mentioned
Daniel 7:25 in the Catholic encyclopedia
here we go
again he posited the standard SDA
assertions around this with a minor
caveat he said the law wasn't actually
changed it was just man's perception of
the law that changed aka the law being a
trans a transcript of God's character
the character of God became aligned
because of Satan and God's vindicating
his
character and that because the law
apparently wasn't seen as design law
late into the early Christian Church
they instead developed the idea that it
was just a set of arbitrary rules that
are
changeable Dr Jennings respectfully you
don't know what you're talking about
here just going to put that out
there we've heard this same thing from
from Doug Bachelor for example
and it's common SDA rhetoric based on
historical revisionism and not actually
being well vered on the actual sources
so let's work down these errant claims I
get frustrated when I hear this because
I'm sick of hearing them lie about
this when this whole thing that he's
presenting here is built on all these
varying steps that he's going through
link after link after Link in the chain
is broken and they need to stop
misrepresenting people first no the
early church didn't see the law as an
arbitrary set of rules that are m
okay the early church understood natural
law like I mentioned earlier in Romans
2 this is what the medieval Scholastics
like Thomas aquinus and the toomas built
upon regarding their understanding of
natural law as we're going to see
later the Thomas did not and do not
claim that the law has been changed this
is a myth that Adventists regularly
assert about the Roman Catholic position
and it is false and it's sad that a
reformed guy like myself has to
constantly point this out but here we
are
again let's prove this before we look at
aquinus this is from Alexander car's a
history of the medieval political theory
in the
West for those unaware Carlile was a a
church historian he speaks about
numerous patristics here meaning early
church fathers who recognized natural
law in scripture notice what he says
quote
the writer known as
ambrosiaster for those that don't know
ambrosiaster is a pseudo pseudonym for
an unknown individual people originally
thought it was Ambrose St Ambrose later
scholarship has determined that that's
probably not the case either way it was
a real individual that lived in the
fourth
Century nevertheless in his commentary
on St Paul's epistle to the Romans he
gives us an interesting tripartite
division of the law that's a three-fold
division like I mentioned earlier moral
monial and civil and a statement of the
relation of the law of nature to the law
of
Moses
ah the definition is interesting but
more significant is the conception of
the relation of the Mosaic law to the
natural law as being something intended
to supplement as well as to confirm
it the same conception is expressed in a
letter of St Ambrose the Mosaic law was
given because men had failed to obey the
natural law again St Ambrose says law is
twofold natural and
written the natural law is in man's
heart the written laws in
tables all men are under law that is
under the
natural
law and again the law of God is in the
heart of the just man which
law not the written but the natural law
for law is is not set for the just but
for the unjust
man the natural law says St Jerome
speaks in our heart telling us to do
what is good and to avoid what is evil
and again he says that whole world
received the natural law and the Mosaic
law was given because the natural law
was neglected or
destroyed it is interesting to notice
that the fathers frequently as we' as we
have before said connect their treatment
of the natural law with St Paul's
phrases in Romans which is what we just
looked
at St Ambrose for instance says that it
is the Apostle who teaches us that the
natural law is in our hearts St
Augustine also refers to St Paul's words
in a passage in which he divides law
into three
species and St Hillary does the same in
describing the general scope of the
natural law close
quote Dr Jennings you could replace the
word natural here with design and say
design
law because Paul is speaking in Romans 1
and 2 about the created order the actual
way that God designed things and what is
hardcoded into the design itself like
respiration he keeps mentioning
respiration the law of
respiration St Ambrose St Augustine St
Jerome origin St
Hillary countless others all support
that this was a wise spread
understanding because of Paul's epistle
to the Romans and this is what laid the
foundation for medieval scholasticism
that would later systematize the present
Roman Catholic belief around the law
which naturally also bled over into the
reformed tradition as
well so he's correct when he claims that
the Christian Church fell into thinking
the law of God or or sorry he's
incorrect when he claims that the
Christian Church fell into thinking the
law of God is just some arbitrary set of
rules that can be
changed and not something that's a part
of God's
design because the law that he has in in
focus is the moral law whether Tim knows
this or not he has inherited the The
Works of
of
ainus dun scotus he he has inherited the
work and labor of the medieval
Scholastics who systematized the
three-fold division of the law that his
movement
upholds yet they'll misrepresent and
slander that
tradition drives me
crazy the crowd that espouses what Tim
is talking about is a fringe minority
antinomians which is a later doctrinal
accretion it's not normative Orthodox
Christian
teaching which is why I'm somewhat
skeptical of Tim's historical theology
in this area and if he's actually done
the heavy lifting and this is going to
be further affirmed later but that's one
second his evidence for this claim was
that the Roman Catholic Church
supposedly removed the second
commandment changed the day of worship
and split the tenth commandment into two
because they don't see God's law as
design law they see it as some arbitrary
list of rules that can
change and he cited the new Catholic
encyclopedia volume 4 to support this
folks this is fiction this is fiction
but here we are once again and we have
to address this because if you make this
claim to a knowledgeable Roman Catholic
you are going to be left with your tail
between your legs your face flush
feeling foolish for having fallen for
such fiction please please
please stop using these arguments please
please because then I and and people
like myself have to deal with your
sloppy work we get saddled with this you
guys don't understand they don't
understand Roman Catholics Orthodox love
saddling us Protestants with this
nonsense they love taking this lwh
hanging fruit and saddling us with it so
please stop just stop and I'm going to
show you why or
starters the Roman Catholic Church
affirms what is called The augustinian
Ordering of the 10 commandments they
didn't remove anything they didn't
remove anything okay lutherans also o
affirmed the augustinian ordering it's
not just Roman
Catholicism this has been a long debate
back to the second and third Century of
the New Testament Church which I'll show
the proof on in a moment but
first
folks here's what Dr Jennings didn't
cite from the Catholic encyclopedia okay
then we're going to show what he
omitted
quote there is no numerical division of
The Commandments in the Books of Moses
but the injunctions are distinctly
tenfold and are found almost identical
in both
sources the order to is the same except
for the final prohibitions pronounced
against concupiscence that of
Deuteronomy being adopted in preference
to
Exodus a confusion however exists in the
numbering which is due to a difference
of opinion concerning the initial
precept of divine
worship meaning the first two
Commandments
technically the first
three the system of numeration found in
Catholic Bibles is based on the Hebrew
text and was made by St Augustine in the
fifth century in his book of questions
of
Exodus and was adopted by the Council of
Trent it is followed also by the German
lutherans except those of the school of
bucer this Arrangement makes the first
commandment relate to false worship and
to the worship of false gods as to a
single subject and a single class of
sins to be guarded against the reference
to Idols being regarded as mere
application of the precept to adore but
one God and the prohibition as directed
against the particular offense of
idolatry
alone according to this manner of
Reckoning the injunction forbidding the
use of the lord's name in vain comes
second in order and the decimal number
is safeguarded by making a division of
the final precept on
concupisent the n pointing to sins of
the Flesh and the 10th to desires for
unlawful possessions of
Goods close
quote so no they didn't remove the
second
commandment there's a longstanding
argument around the numbering because
the Hebrew text doesn't include
numbers in fact there's more than 10
imperatives there's actually 13 I
think the augustinian ordering simply
con joins what many understand as the
second commandment to what we call those
that don't affirm the augustinian
ordering the first because both have to
do with idolatry there's nothing
nefarious going on
here now the evidence of this being an
ancient
debate notice what origin wrote about
this in his homes on Exodus which are
from roughly 220 ad
quote the first commandment therefore is
you shall not have other gods beside me
and after this follows you shall not
make for yourself an idol nor any uh nor
any likeness of anything which is in
heaven above or in the earth beneath or
in the waters under the Earth you shall
neither adore nor worship them for I am
the Lord your God a jealous God who
avenges the sins of the fathers on the
sons to the third and fourth generation
for those who hate me and shows Mercy to
thousands for those who love me and who
keep my Commandments some think that all
these words together are one
commandment but if it be thus supposed
the number 10 of The Commandments will
not be completed and where now will be
the truth of the
decalog but if be divided in that manner
in which we also separated it in the
preceding reading the whole number of
Ten Commandments will
appear the first commandment therefore
is you shall not have other gods besides
me the second is you shall not make for
yourself an idol nor any likeness
Etc close
quote again nothing at all nefarious is
going on none of the imperatives in the
text are being
removed and there isn't any sort of
thinking here that natural law is
mutable there's not numbering in the
Hebrew manuscripts the actual
imperatives have to be recognized and
then some work has to be done on our
part
however Dr Jennings I would highly
advise you to not rely on Doc on Doug
bachelor's propaganda website
sabbathtruth.com
which has gone around and quot minded
all sorts of
sources not even paying attention to
what they're pulling from because Tim
made the same error that Doug Bachelor
did when I had to correct him on this
last year
this is the exact quote that Dr Jennings
put up on his slide only he omitted the
last sentence that's in red and what
does it
say quote the church talking about the
Roman Catholic Church on the other hand
after changing the day of rest from The
Jewish Sabbath or the seventh day of the
week to the first made the third
commandment refer to Sunday as the day
to be kept holy as the Lord's Day the
Council of Trent condemns those who deny
that the Ten Commandments are binding on
Christians close
quote the Council of Trent condemns
what those that deny all Ten
Commandments are binding on
Christians so on the one hand they'll
cite this to try and say see they even
admit that the Pope changed the
Sabbath they read into the phrase the
church and think the Roman Catholic
Church is saying the pope did
this they aren't they mean the
apostles but at the same time they'll
cite it and leave off that last sentence
when trying to talk about the Roman
Catholic Church changing the law
removing some of the Ten Commandments
Etc it is so
dishonest and just so it's clear
they're all getting this from the same
places
folks I've heard Adventists repeat this
till they're blue in the
face they all make the same errors every
single time showing that they haven't
even gone to these sources
themselves they're just repeating what
they've heard from everybody
else here's Doug bachelor's Sabbath
truth propaganda
site where they all get this from and
omit that last sentence as you can see
because it would refute the claim that
they removed some of the Ten
Commandments or have done away with some
of them
Etc but they cite it in this article
which is trying to give a historical
argument for why the Sabbath was changed
and they very clearly omit that last
sentence to try and say look the Roman
Catholic Church even admits they changed
the
Sabbath I will explain how they're
abusing these claims in a
moment but I get so tired of seeing
people within this movement just
outright lie about Roman Catholicism and
Protestants that paired with lazy
research Adventists need to seriously
stop parting the bad homework of other
sdas which misrepresent those they are
critical
of it's always the exact same quotes
exact same sources never more of the
quote the same use of the wrong page
numbers the same use of the of the the
faulty
typos dead giveaway they're all
recycling a single person's homework who
went and deceptively selected the
citations and omitted things that proed
the sources are being
abused commandment keeping Church though
yeah the Roman Catholic Church didn't
change the law because they see it as an
arbitrary list of mutable
commands which is Dr Jennings Central
thesis here to begin building his case
that the investigative judgment needs to
be reimagined and can be salvaged
but not if you have this faulty view of
the atonement being
legal the Roman Catholic Church teaches
that all 10 commandments are binding
upon
people yes including the second
commandment regarding
idolatry you you can disagree with how
they Define such and argue over that but
this silly rhetoric that they change the
law to allow for idolatry which is how
they justify invocation of Saints and
the Maran doctrines give me a break
give me a break I'm so sick of hearing
this engage with what they actually
teach not conspiracy in bad
faith and I understand not all
Adventists do this but this irks me this
irks me this is why I'm so heavy on
sources here Adventists complain all the
time I'm misrepresenting I'm this I'm
that give me a break give me a break but
this Segways us into Daniel 7:25
which Dr Jennings and the SDA Church
Point to as their primary biblical
support piece for all of this and like
we saw in the new Catholic
encyclopedia they state that the church
changed the day of worship so that's
supposed to prove it
right yeah not so
fast I have a running policy on this
platform that anytime I hear this
specific misrepresentation on principle
I will correct it
okay if you're going to critique any
theological framework I don't care whose
it is you have to first understand the
way the model is using language
otherwise it's
pointless it's why for example I showed
earlier what the SDA Church means by the
word atonement I don't just assume they
mean something and then start arguing
that it's why I'm constantly saying that
definitions matter when it comes to
really unraveling aous Theology and
understanding it this is something I
take very
seriously well the same is true when
analyzing what what the Roman Catholic
Church teaches regarding their claims to
quote unquote change the
Sabbath when they say the church changed
the Sabbath or the church changed the
day of
worship Adventists insert the pope into
the phrase the church yeah that's not
what they're
saying that's not what they're
saying the Roman Catholic Church claims
that their institutional hierarchy goes
back to the apostles
namely
Peter specifically for the
papacy when they say the church in this
context they are saying the
apostles they claim the apostles
instituted corporate Worship On the
first day not the
pope they make a distinction as well
between the Law's ceremonial form and
its substance I talk about this all the
time and don't do this silly guilt by
association genetic fallacy where it's
like well the Roman Catholic Church
teaches it so therefore yeah they're not
wrong about everything right about a lot
more than the Adventist Church that's
for sure just shows you hav actually
study what they believe because you've
inherited some of their beliefs whether
you understand this or
not they recognize that the substance of
the fourth Commandment has not changed
and will not change and I'm going to
show you the receipts on this in a
minute we're going to get into Thomas
assuma a qual
qualified or in their case I guess the
Sabbath would be numbered as the the
third commandment not the fourth
Commandment hence why the Council of
Trent says they condemn those who deny
that all Ten Commandments are binding
upon
Christians okay we're going to get a
little bit you're G to have to really
pay attention here folks there's a
reason I don't get into a lot of
scholasticism and stuff on this channel
even though I love the reformed
Scholastics the medieval Scholastics
like Thomas Etc but it's because it it's
it can get a pretty weighty but we have
to look at this now okay we're going to
show beyond a shadow of a doubt that Dr
Jennings has no clue what he's talking
about because he's just parting
information that he got from these other
propaganda sites who also haven't read
this stuff I guarantee you the person
that wrote sabbathtruth.com those
articles all the varying people on there
I guarantee you those individuals have
not read Thomas assuma guarantee it
Thomas is a qualified Roman Catholic
Source on this for those new to this yes
Thomas was a Roman Catholic Theologian
know that doesn't mean he was
automatically wrong or deceived in
everything that he
said my purpose inciting him is to show
how this notion that the Roman Catholic
Church is attacking the Sabbath change
the Ten Commandments is fiction it's a
myth it's not
real and it shows that one doesn't even
have a cursory level reading of the
doctors in the Roman
Church the Suma is Thomas's most famous
theological work it's one of the most
influential writings in Christian
philosophy and theology in the
west It Was Written in the Middle
Ages or what what church historians
would call the the high Middle Ages the
late
1200s and it's broken into three parts
which has significantly shaped present
Roman Catholic theology this is from
article three in part two regarding
whether all the moral precepts of the
Old Law are reducible to the 10 precepts
of the
decalog and he's dealing with objections
that then follow his responses to those
objections that's how it's written
here's an objection here's the response
to the objection so here are the first
two objections that he presents followed
by his responses to them quote objection
one it would seem that not all the moral
precepts of the Old Law are reducible to
the 10 precepts of the decalog for the
first and principal precepts of the law
are Thou shalt love the Lord thy God and
thou shalt love thy neighbor as stated
in Matthew 2237 through
39 but these two were not contained in
the precepts of the
decalogue therefore not all the moral
precepts are contained in the precepts
of the
decalogue that's objection
one so Thomas is going to disagree with
these objections he's going to give
responses objection
two further the moral precepts are not
reducible to the ceremonial precepts but
rather vice versa but among the precepts
of the decalogue one is
ceremonial example remember that thou
keep holy the Sabbath day therefore the
moral precepts are not reducible to all
the precepts of the
decalogue close
quote so before moving forward
Adventist Thomas is responding to the
objection that nine of the Ten
Commandments are moral but the Sabbath
isn't sound
familiar he's arguing the same thing you
guys do you should appreciate him he is
making a Biblical case against the idea
that the Sabbath isn't moral long before
your movement even
existed he then gives his responses to
these object to OB
where first he writes quote I answer
that the precepts of the decalog differ
from the other precepts of the law in
the fact that God himself is said to
have given the precepts of the decalogue
whereas he gave the other precepts to
the people through
Moses sound familiar Adventist
friend for those that don't know adven
say this all the
time yet how many of them would condemn
Thomas to the pit of Hell just because
he's a Roman Catholic sorry wherefore
the decalogue includes those precepts
the knowledge of which man has
immediately from God ah it's written on
the
conscience Romans
2 such are those which with but slight
reflection can be gathered at once from
the first general principles and those
also which become known to man
immediately through divinely infused
Faith consequently two kinds of precepts
are not recog among the precepts of the
decalogue first general
principles for they need no further
promulgation after being once imprinted
on the natural reason to which they are
self-evident that's just a fancy way of
him reiterating Romans 2 like we
saw as for instance that one should do
evil to no man and other similar
principles and again those which the
careful reflection of Wise Men shows to
be in accord with reason since the
people receive these principles from God
though being taught by wise
men nevertheless both kinds of precepts
are contained in the precepts of the
decalogue yet in different
ways for the first general principles
are contained in them as principles in
their proximate conclusions while those
which are known through wise men are
contained conversely as conclusions in
their
principles close quote so before moving
forward guess what s
Adventist Thomas here is explaining the
unique status of the decalogue compared
to the other laws in the Old Testament
sound
familiar because Thomas is the one who
systematized that word does not mean
originated by the way there's some
Adventists that confuse the I've heard
this numerous times I've read articles
where they say this Etc systematized
does not mean originated remember that
carile quote that we read earlier ambro
Aster talks about this I have ambro
Aster's commentary on Romans and he does
he makes a three-fold distinction when
when commentating on the book that's
long before Thomas almost a thousand
years before
Thomas but Thomas is the one who
systematized the three-fold distinction
between the moral ceremonial and civil
law and his argument is that the Ten
Commandments are unique because God
himself gave them directly to the people
unlike other laws that were communicated
by God through
Moses and he argues that the decalogue
contains moral precepts that are
immediately known to humans either
through natural reason aka the
conscience or what Thomas calls divinely
infused
faith meaning they are a part of natural
law the created order they transcend
Moses he's advocating for the exact same
thing the Adventist Church does in this
regard
this is a doctor of the Roman Catholic
Church friend not a Joe
Schmo now notice two of his other
replies where he speaks about the
Sabbath
commandment so reply to objection one he
G an he gives an overview General
rebuttal and now he gives specific
replies to the objections so what was
objection
one when somebody says it would seem
that not all the moral precepts of the
Old Law are reducible to the 10 because
well Jesus said the whole law is
summarized by love for God and love for
neighbor and that's not found in the
10 to which Thomas
says quote those two principles are the
first general principles of the natural
law and are self-evident to human reason
either through nature or through faith
wherefore all the precepts of the
decalog are referred to these as
conclusions to general
principles AKA
well I I don't want to Sidetrack on that
I could have a lot to say on that but
notice reply to objection
two the precept of the Sabbath
observance is moral in one respect in so
far as it commands man to give some time
to the things of God according to Psalm
4610 be still and see that I am God in
this respect it is placed among the
precepts of the decalog but not as to
the fixing of the time in which respect
it is a cereem monial
precept close
quote so Thomas didn't make didn't even
make an exception for the Sabbath
commandment not being moral but that the
others
are no he taught and believed that all
10 are moral but that there is a
substantive difference between the
ceremonial form of the Sabbath
commandment meaning the way that it's
walked out and observed and practiced
versus the actual substance of the
command itself
the moral aspect is that it commands
people to dedicate time to God which is
a universal principle I.E Psalm
4610 the specific requirement to observe
the seventh day
Saturday is ceremonial in nature the
substance is transcendent the cere the
ceremonial form is
not I talk about this all the time
because the form Scholastics built upon
and inherited this from Thomas and
Thomas wasn't wrong he was correct in
his
observation the ceremonial form of the
fourth Commandment specifically changes
throughout Redemptive history Just
Between the first and second giving of
the
law and just like the rest of natural
law is transcendent days are not
Transcendent they're not
Eternal that's a part of the ceremonial
aspect of the
law so Tim Jennings is wrong
because Thomas is an accurate
spokesperson for Roman Catholic teaching
even if you don't agree with him
especially late medieval teaching which
is supposed to be man we're like way
past when this whole concept of the laws
understanding has changed to this
malleable Imperial sort of
thing and Thomas is arguing that an
aspect of the Sabbath is a part of
natural law which is unchanging or
design law as Tim Jennings has referred
to it
I said I've talked about this a lot
regarding the Sabbath
because it just it totally decimates the
aous understanding of the Sabbath
folks but I haven't utilized Thomas
because it will cause some people
unfortunately to just dismiss him
because he was Roman Catholic but this
is
spoton there is a ceremonial form of the
Sabbath Commandment that can change and
a moral aspect that cannot change
the ceremonial can change because it's
not built into nature it's not hardwired
it's not uh en encoded into the actual
DNA the moral aspect is and ultimately
at its core the Sabbath is about the
gospel which is why the seven amist
Church doesn't actually keep the Sabbath
they think because they go to church on
Saturday they keep the
Sabbath no Frank you guys are like
Israel wandering around out in the
wilderness
in the desert of
life where you think you've entered in
because you're observance of of Shadows
and types and
ceremony but just like them if you don't
believe you're not going to enter in and
you're going to perish and you're going
to die out in the
wilderness but that is the Roman
Catholic position in this area which is
why that was my whole point in citing
that an actual official primary source
most of the sources folks that people
site in this area that abist cite in
this area look they said they changed
the Sabbath they're not even
authoritative it's a random priest or a
cardinal somewhere that said something
now that doesn't make it an official
primary
source Thomas assuma is a primary source
he's a doctor in the Roman Catholic
Church look up what that means he's a
doctor in the Roman Church okay he's not
just a priest
so I'm sorry but Dr Jennings just does
not know what he's talking about in this
area or any other Adventist for that
matter who makes the claim that the
Roman Catholic Church degrades The Ten
Commandments removes some of the
Commandments hates the Sabbath Etc I'm
sorry miss me with that it just patently
false get new
arguments so to any Adventist that hears
this before slandering Roman Catholicism
you should be grateful for Thomas
aquinus work in this area of the
three-fold division of of the law and
for providing some of the best biblical
defenses for such as well as some of the
strongest biblical and rational
arguments in favor of all Ten
Commandments being moral in
nature
thirdly the vast majority of quotes that
you'll hear Adventist site regarding
them changing the Sabbath are
post-reformation
statements they are Roman Catholic
responses to the Protestant Reformation
and this matters remember I'm addressing
here these charges that look they even
admit that they changed the
Sabbath and they'll point to these
quotes and not understand what's being
said they're not saying the pope did
this they're not saying the Commandments
can change and have changed Etc the
moral commands natural law Etc but
thirdly these statements are
post-reformation and this
matters because in this discussion the
subject of apostolic succession is one
that is Paramount and the Roman Catholic
Church's reasoning goes as
follows if the apostles instituted the
first day of corporate worship and the
reformers broke away from that
institution that Jesus instituted with
the apostles I.E the Roman Catholic
Church then Protestants have no basis
for first day corporate
worship especially considering that no
text in scripture verbatim says
such make sense you got the reasoning if
it was instituted by the apostle
and the reformers broke away from the
apostles then Protestants have no basis
for what the apostles established that's
the reasoning in the argument which is
why if you read John Calvin's institutes
L uh uh Martin kemet's on this and his
response to Trent all these varying
things where they're going back and
forth on this the topic of apostolic
succession ends up getting naturally
brought up because that's what's going
on here but with the reformed in
particular which is the tradition I'm a
part
of that's who some of these quotes are
specifically levied at and the Roman
Catholic Church is arguing against
What's called the regulative principle
of
worship the regulative principle is the
belief that corporate
worship should only contain that which
is prescribed in
scripture which is why we don't use
icons or images and fog machines and
laser lights Etc
so since this is the case the Roman
Catholic church has argued that since
reformed Christians affirm solos
scriptura as well as the regulative
principle of worship we therefore have
no basis for corporate first day worship
because there's no biblical text that
explicitly says to worship that
day see the
argument I obviously don't agree with
the argument but I'm trying to steal man
and present to you the
reasoning that's the context of a lot of
these quotes that Adventists site where
Rome makes these claims about
Protestants having no basis for
corporate first day worship because they
changed the day of worship to the first
day and then the reformed have their
arguments and we go back and forth on
these things and the rest is history but
the point being the Roman Catholic
Church is not claiming what Adventists
claim they are full
stop Adventists are citing quotes that
they don't understand the backstory and
context of and are then importing into
those quotes their Adventist
presuppositions such as the pope
changing the Sabbath because that's what
Ellen White claimed to be shown in
Vision if you're an Adventist please
please please stop doing this it's not
moving the conversation
forward it's like the bad evangelic it's
not just Adventists it's like the bad
evangelicals too who who just they mean
well I get it I get it but it's
exhausting stop with these bad arguments
it just it it's embarrassing it is
embarrassing
please if you continue to do so after
hearing this you are a dishonest person
and you don't have
integrity because you can make
legitimate arguments against Roman
Catholic theology without straw Manning
and misrepresenting them to try and
bolster your own view if you have to do
that you evidence your position is
weak same goes for your arguments
against Protestant prots too learn what
people actually believe go to the
sources
yourself as it pertains to Daniel
7:25 now the rest of the night could be
spent on
this because he tried to say we all know
the history Daniel 7 and the the the
little horn changed the law and yeah the
latter half of Daniel 7 which includes
verse 25 is a prophecy of the church is
suffering under oppressive rulers the
little horn and Dan's Prophecy with
rulers particularly Roman
Caesars who waged open war against the
church and were on a crusade to
extinguish her but
failed this is interconnected with the
understanding that that the church is
Christ
Kingdom the changing of times and laws
is the Caesar's attempt to overthrow
Christ's Kingdom the
church which is also how it can have
present day application to us mind you
and every subsequent generation be
before us
which is similar to the overarching
message of Revelation which as
Adventists are aware Daniel is
intimately connected with
Revelation the modern application is the
reminder that Jesus is overcome he's
ruling and reigning his kingdom will
continue advancing leading to the
consummation of the
ages but Tim said he thinks the change
there is referring to the way people see
or understand the law not the actual
changing of the day
so it's the Warped understanding of
God's character because remember when
they talk about God's law they're also
talking about his character and his
government all those terms are
synonymous in this
model great controversy Satan began
attacking the Ten Commandments and it's
actually that the character of God has
been maligned because they think this
law is Imperial and it's all this stuff
it's all built on this same
fundamentally flawed
Foundation interesting
take but I'd argue even that's flawed
because Christians have always believed
in design law or natural law that's not
even what's in focus in Daniel
7 it's just word association or word
concept fallacy on his
part opening that can of worms all of
Daniel 7 would require getting into
prophetic School of interpretation and
why One Superior over against
another is uus the first church
historian and notice what he writes with
the Roman Empire monarchy had come on
Earth as the image of the monarchy in
heaven
you understand what that says the the
imperial system that crucified
Christ is now Christianity this is the
Christian first Christian historian not
World historian Christian church
historian is telling us that God runs
his government like Caesar runs
Rome this is Lindsay's uh book on
history of the Reformation it says the
Great Men Who Built the western church
were almost all trained Roman lawyers
chulian cyprian Augustine Gregory the
Great whose writings formed the bridge
between the Latin fathers and schoolmen
were all men whose early training had
been that of Roman lawyer a training
which molded and shaped all their
thinking whether theological or
ecclesiastical they instinctively
regarded all questions as a great Roman
lawyer would they had the lawyer's
cravings for exact definitions that the
lawyer's idea that the primary Duty laid
upon them was to enforce obedience to
Authority whether that Authority
expressed itself in external
institutions or in the precise
definitions of the correct ways of
thinking about spiritual truth you know
the thought police these are the
doctrines these are the Creeds these are
the 28 fundamentals you better adhere to
them no branch of Western
christiandom has been able to free
itself from the spell cast upon it by
these Roman lawyers of the early
centuries of the Christian
Church imperialism God's laws like our
law and when you break our law Justice
requires the ruling Authority must
punish and there must be accounting
there must be a record in some record
book of all the sins and those sins have
to have some payment made for them and
there's some has to be some time in
history when the judge will go in and
look at the records and see who's been
paid and who's not been paid the entire
investigative judgment has been
corrupted by Imperial law which is not
God's
law Psalm
711 God is a righteous judge and a God
who feels indignation Every Day psalm
50:6 the heavens declare his
righteousness for God himself is Judge
Isaiah
33:22 for the Lord is our judge the Lord
is our lawgiver the Lord is our King he
will save
us Ezekiel 18:30 therefore I will judge
you oh House of Israel everyone
according to his ways declares the Lord
God repent and turn from all your
transgressions lest iniquity be your
ruin Dr Jennings the Bible is what
presents God in this way and uses this
type of
language the issue isn't the legal
aspect of sin or recognizing the legal
framework that God has revealed about
himself through scripture such as that
he's a
judge and the judge isn't the one on
trial folks SDA theology has it entirely
Twisted that God is the one on
trial the problem is the investigative
judgment in Adventist theology not the
not the legal language in the Bible he
said we've got it all twisted Ellen
White got it all twisted then sir that's
where this is primarily coming from your
church is informing this teaching based
on her commentary on such and she
claimed to get this directly direct
Revelation from God on this
stuff these the Neo Adventist folks have
got to know they've got to know that
this is just a death blow to the system
that just twisting things and you're
he's saying white got this wrong that's
what he's saying he didn't word it that
way but that's what he's essentially
that's the the conclusion of what he's
saying the investigative judgment has
been inflicted with this and warped by
this Oh you mean God through Ellen White
okay the fact that the Bible speaks this
way about God and His dealing with sin
and Justice doesn't necessitate the
investigative judgment and all the
problematic details that he
presented that there's a list of of sins
and a record books
and that that if
it's that well if there if it's
legal that would require God examining
the books like how the investigative
judgment Doctrine claims folks Paul had
a legal background and he penned most
the new
testament which is why like I showed
earlier he himself in Colossians 2
equates sin with debt and explains how
our sins being placed on Christ at the
cross can out that debt that stood
against us which is legal language the
word itself is a legal term go look it
up kogon it's only used one place in the
whole
Bible and it literally is a legal
term but more
importantly I hinted at this or or said
a little bit about this you know just a
second ago but I just want to reiterate
he just admitted that Ellen White is a
false prophet that didn't actually
receive re
Visions she didn't receive the vision
she claimed to receive
apparently because he said an imperial
idea and understanding of the law has
infected the investigative judgment yet
it's the Adventist propheus who claim to
be shown this
Invision so maybe Tim is one of these
Adventists that rejects Ellen White I
don't know he's an Adventist
light wouldn't Shock Me with the Neo
Adventist crowd but it's a perfect
example of how any sort of deviation
from Adventist Orthodoxy actually
nullifies the validity of
adventism because Orthodox Adventist
theology demands that all of it be true
including what Ellen White put forth
regarding the investigative judgment or
the system collapses and adventism
unique identity becomes
nullified which is why so many
Adventists think that what Tim is
teaching is an infiltration into their
movement and that he's a deceiver
leading people away from present
truth but I'll tell you what's
fascinating about all this is that I
decided to do some digging on Tim's
claims here and notice what I
found so you can go to character of
good.com character ofg
good.com a website that's run by an
Adventist guy which puts forth The
Identical thing that Tim is saying using
the exact same sources every single one
of them notice what he
writes this individual quote Under The
Heading a change to God's
law but this truth was lost and another
concept of law replaced it
romanism Imperial Rome's concept of
government and law infected Christian
thought after the emperor Constantine
converted prior to Constantine's
conversion Christianity understood God's
law as the law of Love Therefore love is
the Fulfillment of the law ah and then
the proof text that Tim has been
using but after Constantine's conversion
which should say conversion or sorry but
after Constantine
converted the Christian Church accepted
Rome's change to God's law and what was
that
change that God's law is an imposed law
with no inherent consequence thus
requiring the lawgiver to police
breaches in the law and inflict
punishment rather than the truth that
God's law is the natural law of love the
design protocol on which God created
life to operate eus the first church
historian documented clearly how
Christianity exchanged God's law of love
for an imposed Roman construct quote
there are no reserves in this in the
styled ionium with which yeus closes his
history no wistful regret for the
blessings of persecution no prophetic
fear of Imperial control of the church
his heart is full of gratitude to God
and Constantine and it's not only his
feelings that are stirred he's ready
with a theory indeed a Theology of the
Christian Empire or Emperor he finds a
correspondence between religion and
politics with the Roman Empire monarchy
had come on Earth as the image of the
monarchy in
heaven and then what quote do we see the
same one that that Dr Jennings just
cited Thomas Lindsay in his book a
history of the Reformation describes
this infection in Christian thought this
way same thing terlan cyprian Augustine
Gregory yada
yada but so because yeus documents down
that the Roman monarchy was a picture of
Heaven on Earth which is what he's
getting at if you go read it that proves
that Christianity supposedly exchanged
God's law of love for an imposed Roman
construct I challenge anyone to go in
and read this from yeus okay it's in his
book life of Constantine Yus was a
historian that was his primary strength
he did some commentary type type stuff
but his
his accolades are in church
history this is not what yeus is saying
in this quote this is another case of
them taking statements that they don't
understand and reading into them ideas
that are not being being conveyed yeus
saw Constantine as a divinely appointed
ruler whose monarchy mired the Heavenly
Kingdom you have to put yourself in the
shoes of these individuals don't read
them anachronistically from 2025 and
then like try and make him look like he
he's of today he's not let them be what
they are let the fathers be the fathers
let yeus be
Yus this is coming from his historical
work so the general claimed that yes
yeus believed that Constantine was
divinely appointed and this is because
you're talking about years of
persecution of the
church brutal persecution you know AVST
want to talk about being persecuted for
going to church on Saturday yeah read
yeus is documenting down of what was
taking place around 70 AD okay real
persecution aanus the great persecution
this is from his historical work that
he's talking about here life of
Constantine where he presents
Constantine's reign as a fulfillment of
divine order suggesting basically that
Earthly monarchy should reflect Heavenly
monarchy again this was years after
severe persecution so he saw this as
this amazing look at this Turning Point
thing where we go from Diocesan and all
these persecutions leading to the actual
Emperor being converted and Christianity
becoming legal
ized
however
however uus does not argue or claim that
Christians transitioned from viewing
God's law as love to an imperialistic
framework contextually he was focused on
legitimizing Constantine's
Rule and the integration of the church
with the Roman state
not on a theological shift regarding the
nature of God's law so while he may
reflect on intertwining of Christian
theology with Imperial
Authority I.E the church and the
state this does not support the claim
that he advocated a move from a
love-based understanding of God's law to
one characterized by imperialism because
it's malleable and it can change and all
this other
stuff so you cus is being abused and
twisted to sound like he's saying what
this theory is claiming he
isn't he's not documenting down that
this led to Christians to go from seeing
God's law of love to one of
imperialism this is the great
controversy worldview coloring the lines
for them where they see youus mention
God's
government which what does that mean in
the Adventist
mind the law The Ten Commandments God's
character
Ellen White synonymously used those
phrases God's government to refer to
those things she synonymously used God's
government to refer to the Ten
Commandments the law Etc That's what
Satan began attacking was God's
government are you connecting the
dots this worldview is coloring the
quote for
them so because the Roman Empire was an
imperial one and Constantine is talking
uh about the the
or or or Yus is talking about the
government of Heaven breaking into the
government on Earth they think
something's being said that isn't yeus
didn't have a great controversy
worldview it wasn't even talking about
Christian understanding of the law and
and and it being changed but guess what
folks guess
what it doesn't end
there
because here's Tim Jennings website
after going to character ofg good.com
which for all I know maybe that is Tim
Jennings own separate website some
second website I don't
know but I then went to come andreas.com
and guess
what he took this same article from
character ofg god.com identically so
same sources everything
verbatim with what we saw previously
regarding the Catholic
encyclopedia there's youus Thomas
Lindsay I mean Franks up
here with what we saw previously
regarding the Catholic encyclopedia I'm
not even convinced that Dr Jennings has
read the sources that he's citing to
understand what's even being said he's
just recycling all these same sources
and statements that they all use and
they got from each other going back to
one individual somewhere
Daniel 7:25 has nothing to do with the
papacy or the converted Christian Roman
Empire changing the understanding of
God's law from being a law of Love or
design into a mutable Imperial list of
Dos and do not restrictions that are
changeable but notice what Tim actually
says in this
article on his website from the one that
was just on screen
okay what we were looking at is act from
the preface of his own paraphrase of the
Bible like I mentioned earlier the
remedy yes he has his own Bible
paraphrase and if you think the Blurred
word aka the clear word was bad yeah go
check this one out but in the preface of
that paraphrase this is what he writes
right after utilizing that same Thomas
Lindsay quote
quote Christians lost sight of God's law
of love and instead accepted an imposed
law system modeled after human
governments ah just like he said in the
presentation
earlier after all if they still believed
God's law was the designed law of Love
Like The Law of respiration there it is
again then would they ever have thought
a church committee could vote to change
such a law something the church did vote
in committee to do but they could only
vote to change God's law after they
first accepted the concept that his law
is imposed not natural
this idea of an imposed law altered the
view of uh the view of God held by
Christians and changed how Christianity
functioned thus Christians went from a
body of believers who lived communally
shared their possessions to help each
other and died as Martyrs to an
organization of Crusades Inquisition
burning denters at the stake and active
participation in genocide Nazis in
Germany and Christians in
Wanda close
quote so the Inquisition and the
Crusades were a result of Christian
lawyers like like tulan St Augustine St
cyprian coming from a legal background
and influencing the way that the law
should be understood for the
Christian and just like in that
character of god.com article he cited
Thomas Lindsay to support this along
with the
cus so so before tulan and Augustine
cyprian Etc in the third through fifth
centuries Christians had an
understanding of God's law as one of
love but then these Giants of the
Christian
faith they came along and distorted all
that they distorted the character of God
these these
lawyers but this could only happen after
it was first accepted that God's law is
imposed
and not
what
natural yeah what Tim is sharing here is
historical fiction folks I'm sorry but
if you're an Adventist that has fallen
for this my advice would be to go and
get a
refund go get your lunch money
back but then he continues pay very
close attention because we're getting to
the heart of the matter
quote sadly by the time the Bible was
eventually translated into the language
of the people the imposed law construct
was deeply ingrained
Orthodoxy essentially all Bible
translations have been done by people
operating through the lens of imposed
the law what this means is that Bible
translations artificially introduce
imposed law with fear inducing ideas
about God
this Bible paraphrase offers an
alternative my bias is that God is the
creator Builder and designer and when he
constructed his Universe he built it to
operate in harmony with his own nature
of Love thus God's law is not a set of
imposed rules but the design parameters
on which he built life to exist close
quote so ditch every other actual Bible
translation and trade it out for Tim's
paraphrase which isn't even a
translation but is a paraphrase that
funnels the Bible through an extra
biblical Paradigm called the Great
controversy
theme entirely unknown until a woman in
the 19th century claimed to be shown
Visions from
God through which this Paradigm
supposedly claim or or came he
continues the remedy is an expanded
Bible paraphrase in which interpretation
is filtered through through the lens of
God's design law of love the template on
which life is
built this paraphrase is intentional in
its focus to reorient the Christian mind
to God's character of love and his
mission to heal and restore humankind as
taught by the early church close
quote but there at the end we have the
code words so ditch your actual Bible
translation which supposedly has a bent
against natural law
and seeing God's true character and Trad
it in for Tim Jennings paraphrase which
isn't even a translation and is filtered
through the great controversy
lens go check this thing out folks a
total Onslaught butchering of the
Bible yeah
yeah but this is the same fault
narrative that he mentioned at the
beginning of his presentation that early
Christians basically looked like
Adventists because they had Selfless
Love which was a result of them having
the correct understanding of God's
character but then the big bad Roman
Catholic church and Constantine came
along and warped that understanding and
now there's a false understanding and
Satan was ultimately behind it because
this war started in heaven where he was
attacking God's
character the same stuff we hear and see
from other Neo Adventists who still
promote the idea that God is on trial
and his character is in question but
they don't like various other aspects
that make up the aous system of theology
so they try and repackage those parts or
in some instances just outright reject
them but at the end of the day this
reimagining by Jennings is still the
same theological dumpster fire it's
still coming from the same unbiblical
Adventist worldview and faulty
understanding that God his law his
character they're on trial Etc
it all goes back to that that's why I'm
constantly bringing this
up that's now we're found in the Bible
that Satan prior to Earth's existence
began attacking the Ten Commandments and
telling Angels you don't need any
government self-governance is the best
government and he tried to seek his own
government so God had to hold a council
meeting and they decided they permit it
to happen because if God just blotted
him out it would confirm Satan's claims
to the angels and seow seeds of doubt in
their mind none of this crap is in the
Bible that's what it is it is crap and
if you think that word is bad you need
to go look at what Paul said when he
talked about
scoon I'm not going to say what that
word is but go check it out for yourself
if you think crap is bad because that's
what this stuff is it's from the dung
pile of
theology the Bible is what uses legal
imagery to reveal certain realities Dr
Jennings I understand you don't like
this I understand some a lot of people
don't it's not just him
but it's not because of Christian
lawyers in history imposing such a view
on the Bible not the pope not the Roman
Catholic Church not Christians who
distorted and warped the character of
God and his law by retrofitting a legal
idea into the Bible the Bible itself
uses legal wording and imagery to convey
certain
realities none of that necessitates the
investigative judgment though the the
problem is not the legality of sin or
God's law the issue is the investigative
judgment and adventism
instead of claiming everyone else ruined
things which borders on conspiracy just
just apply William aam's
Razer which very clearly points to
adventism novel theology being the
problem not everyone else but hey may
maybe aam's razor is again is you know
aam was a part of the the the medieval
Scholastics so maybe we can't use that
either because that's tainted by reason
and and these sorts of things but the
the early church did not have a great
controversy worldview which is in formed
shaped and framed by the writings of
elen white I've shown the sources on
this enough at this point there's no
need to unpack that
again Daniel prophesied I watched the
horn was Waging War against the Saints
and defeating them we were losing the
war
until till the ancient a came and
pronounced judgment in favor of the
Saints well what kind of war is
this what kind of
War notice what it says in Cor thians 2
Corinthians 10 3-5 for though we live in
the world we do not wage war as the
world does the weapons we use they're
not worldly they have divine power to
demolish strongholds what do we demolish
we demolish arguments and every
pretention that sets itself up against
now here's the core issue in the war the
knowledge of God and take captive every
thought to Jesus Christ now if you're in
a battle in a war over knowledge
arguments pretensions and thoughts
where's the
battlefield the battlefield your
mind and the war Satan is the father of
lies and Hees get you to believe lies
we're going to go into that this
afternoon how lies actually affect your
neural circuitry and your brain
structure as he gets you to believe lies
he exerts power of you that's why Jesus
said the truth will set you free exactly
we're in a war that centers over the
knowledge of
god wow okay so once
again another textbook example of this
movement not utilizing the historical
grammatical method of Bible
interpretation despite the leadership
insisting that's the only approved
hermeneutic Tim engaged in word concept
or word association
fallacy he took the word War found in
Daniel 7 and then jumped to 2
Corinthians 10 where the same word is
used and tried to make some sort of
interpretive Cory between the two so
notice his reasoning he cited Daniel 721
through 22 and said Daniel prophesied
that the horn and focus waged war
against the Saints and was defeating
them and we were losing the war until
the Ancient of Days came and pronounced
judgment in favor of the Saints then he
asked well what kind of war is this to
Define such he hopscotched over to 2
Corinthians 10 found the word war and
said the battlefield is the mind and
we're in a war that centers on the
knowledge of God aka the character of
God is being attacked by Satan and God
is on trial and needs Vindicated from
these
attacks and for those who may think I'm
nitpicking here no I'm
not He is building his case here and
like we're going to see in part two he's
going to get more specifically into his
reinterpretation of this this is his
setting the stage and the and the
foundation to build upon well if that's
cracked and flawed this whole thing
falls
apart this is the same great controversy
world view packaged in a different skin
folks same stuff we hear from all the
other Neo Adventist types who are always
talking about pop
psychology that the real problem is man
has a distorted picture in his mind of
the character of God and that's the real
problem and that's why they're hostile
to him so if we can get you know if we
can remedy that and AD can just change
people's perspect P perception of who
God actually is that's what will result
in people coming to him now that that's
not man's problem that that's not man's
problem the unregenerate man's problem
is he is a hater of God cannot do any
good cannot seek for God is actively
hostile toward him loves his sin
suppresses the truth and unrighteousness
is born in in dead in sins and
trespasses doesn't come to the light
because he knows it will expose his sin
and so on those are all biblical
claims explicit statements in scripture
about the unregenerate man and why he
needs to be born again he doesn't need a
pop psychology lesson to try and put a
new image in the unregenerate person's
mind about who God
is but I want to look at how the Bible
was abused here because Tim crossed
wires and if you aren't paying close
enough attention it makes sense why a
person could think his conclusion was
valid cuz he's just rattling through the
stuff and I get it you know he's doing a
presentation
Etc Daniel 7: 21-22 and 2 Corinthians 10
3-5 are only related in the sense that
both passages speak about conflict and
victory but they address entirely
different contexts and types of
battles so it's a superficial
appeal why I said he engaged in in a
form of word concept
fallacy Daniel 7: 21-22 is describing a
vision where a horn
representative of an oppressive power
not going to get into arguing what what
power but that power makes war against
the Saints and prevails until God
intervenes giving the Saints Victory and
then pronounces a judgment in their
favor this is an eschatological prophecy
about persecution and God's ultimate
Justice which is somewhat ironic given
Tim's objection to legal and law type
language regarding judgment
nevertheless 2 Corinthians 10 is is
talking about spiritual warfare where
Paul explains that believers do not
fight using physical weapons but instead
use divine power to destroy arguments
and strongholds that oppose the
knowledge of God fting deception and and
falsehood with
truth so both passages are addressing
conflict involving God's people but
Daniel 7 focuses on external
persecution and God vindicating his
people from that persecution
not himself or his
character while 2 Corinthians 10 focuses
on spiritual warfare and a battle
against false
ideas yet when Tim asked what kind of
war is Daniel 7 referring to he appealed
to 2 Corinthians 10 3 through five to
Define such no Daniel 7 is talking about
external
conflict 2 Corinthians 10 is talking
about spiritual warfare against false
ideologies Daniel 7's not talking about
to battle over knowledge arguments
pretensions and thoughts in the mind and
a false understanding of God's
character see the
issue the context of the two is not the
same and they definitely don't prove
that God and his character are on trial
because of Satan and now God has to
vindicate himself from these accusations
which is the underlaying Assumption in
the driver's seat of Dr Jennings that
he's operating
on remember what Tim is seeking to do
here he's building the case for his
unique reimagining of the investigative
judgment he thinks Orthodox SDA teaching
in this area is flawed because it
Embraces this Imperial understanding of
the law that the Christian Church
allegedly adopted which has set the
teaching forth in a legal fearful
framework over and against a loving
natural design sense and along the way
he tried using Daniel 7 and 2
Corinthians 10 as a support piece to
build up the foundational idea that God
and his love are on trial because love
is a part of his
character so far this presentation is
built on sinking
sand this wasn't a sound handling of the
Bible and it definitely wasn't an
application of the historical
grammatical
method you have to be on the lookout for
fallacious reasoning like this that can
appear to be biblical since similar
wording is being used and the Bible is
being appealed
to but this was not sound hermeneutic
it was a support piece in this larger
edifice he is he is seeking to build to
make it seem biblical along the
way now in part two we will see how he
brings this faulty Foundation to the
doctrine of the investigative judgment
itself and begins to flesh out an
entirely novel understanding of such and
we'll get into the finer specifics of
his reimagining of the investigative
judgment but the point of part one was
this that at the end of the day folks
Tim Jennings still has a great
controversy worldview that he is pushing
no differently than any other abous
leader it is still the same poisonous
roote despite his departure from SDA
Orthodoxy as a Neo Adventist he's still
promoting the same product that the SDA
church is trying to sell us on he just
uses a different approach to do so
different packaging they all do it
it is the theological lipstick on a pig
approach you've got some folks out there
they're just going to show you the pig
here it is you need to accept
it the others they're like oh man that
pig has some mud on it let's slap some
lipstick on it that'll do the trick the
mud is still there friends that the mud
is still
there this is the same approach we see
with other Neo Adventist types like Ty
Gibson and his ministry lightbe
who we've listened to before what is
lightbearer
tagline remember we looked at it the
last time we look well no it wasn't the
last time one of the previous times we
looked at Ty
Gibson they State on their website that
their mission is to vindicate the beauty
of God's
character that's the central big idea if
you will of the Adventist Church's extra
biblical worldview that comes from Ellen
White not the
Bible and it revolves around the idea
that before the Earth even existed Satan
began attacking the Ten Commandments in
heaven and now God is on
trial and the Earth and human beings
were created with this controversy over
the Ten Commandments God's government
already underway with the goal being
that Adam and Eve would vindicate God by
keeping the law perfectly AKA his
government which would silence Satan but
they failed which made it appear like
Satan had the victory but the Son of God
then offered to come after a council
meeting at the risk of Eternal
loss I've heard people like Doug
Bachelor say that yeah Jesus could have
failed and if he would have it would
have been Eternal division in
god wow the things some of them will say
it's like do you stop to think before
you talk
dude but the Son of God offered to come
at the risk of Eternal loss to do what
Adam failed to do and proed to Fallen
humans that the law can be kept it can't
change and with God's help you can keep
the law and prove Satan's a liar inside
with Jesus in the great
controversy and in that model that's
what Redemptive history is all about
allegedly the Ten Commandments being
Vindicated Satan being proven to be a
liar God is on trial none of that is
biblical and I'm sorry administ friend
if you believe that you have it
backwards you're not the judge
friend you have it completely
backwards your you're not the
judge and if you don't understand that
I've got bad news for
you it's time to really start thinking
these things through friend some of
y'all have been with me a long time
years you know that this stuff is
stirring within you it's time it's
time it's time to give this up I know
it's difficult I get it it's time to
give this mess up and come be a
Christian they bring this concept to the
Bible from Ellen White's writings it's
already accepted as valid from that
point it's then brought to the Bible to
then try and find ways to make it appear
like the Bible supports
it and it's why a lot of these Neo
Adventists are big into pop psychology
in adopting modern psychological
approaches in their teaching style
because at the root they think the
problem is the picture is is is that
people have a picture of God that's
faulty in their mind and since that's
the case that's what keeps them from
coming to God they don't understand his
true character and if we can just fix
that then they'll come to
him so they place this big emphasis on
trying to influence the psychology of an
individual when that's not the roote
issue that's why so many Adventists
don't have peace your issue is not your
psychology friend there's a deeper
issue you need born
again but but see adventism doesn't
understand the nature of man they don't
understand the real problem they think
the Holy Spirit communicates to you in
your brain and that's why the health
message comes in because you need to
keep your mind in the
clearest
yeah Jesus said the wicked don't come to
the light because they hate the light
knowing that it will expose their sin
Romans 1 says that they love their sin
and suppress the truth of God in their
unrighteousness Paul says everyone knows
God exists but because they love their
sin they exalt other things in the place
of God to try and suppress that innate
knowledge that's
obvious it's like you go outside you
look up at the stars and then people
seriously try to say oh it's just happen
stance no you're coming up with
excuses they try to suppress the truth
that's obvious from both natural
Revelation the creation itself as well
as Divine special Revelation in the
Sacred Scriptures it is not a
psychological cognitive issue it's a
spiritual death
issue so the solution that the AVST
church is is trying to provide is not
the actual antidote it's not the real
remedy no pun
intended that's the crazy thing is Tim
jennings's paraphrase is called the
remedy but he doesn't even have the
remedy it's Fool's Gold the only
solution friend the only
solution is that God in his mercy and
Grace raises the spiritually dead sinner
to newness of Life giving them eyes to
see and ears to hear resulting in their
positive response to the call of the
Gospel you may ask how do I how do I do
that how do I get that you need to fall
on your knees and beg God
you need to repent of thinking that God
is on trial and that you're the judge in
the judge's seat determining whether you
think he's worthy of what he
is you're not the judge you're a
creature you have a creature Creator
issue here that's another thing we need
to start talking about that adventism
does not understand the creature Creator
distinction they got it completely
backwards but this is why we have to be
taking the gospel to Adventist a lot of
you are new here we've seen a huge
uptick of non former sdas Christians of
various stripes and traditions welcome
hop in there's a lot of space in the bus
and we're going at break next speed the
momentum is already going at this point
you got to start getting caught up we
have to be taking the gospel to
Adventists especially the Neo Adventist
types they are harder to reach than
Orthodox Adventists because people like
Ty Gibson and David Aster and Tim
Jennings and the other Neo Adventists
try and make adventism seem fresh with
these new ideas and pop psychology and
evang Evangelical is Vibes but at the
end of the day it's the same old product
in a new rapper do not be
fooled just understand that this sort of
stuff is out there in the Adventist
world it's not Orthodox by the book
adventism it's actually more dangerous
because it better conceals the
deception but we will pick back up on
this in part two we will listen to more
of Tim's reimagine theory for how the
investigative judgment can actually be a
great teaching if you understand it the
way he is hypothesized but until then
may Christ richly bless you in the grace
and peace won by him and his vicarious
death on the cross for Sinners until
next time God bless
[Music]